so if you thought that the United States
had become a global laughingstock thanks
to Donald Trump before three days ago
then the u.s. is really doubly a
laughingstock right now the world is
literally laughing at the United States
because we have a dangerous fool as
president who is still supported by tens
of millions of Americans who recently
suggested we should look into injecting
bleach and isopropyl alcohol to treat
coronavirus here is the chief medical
officer in Australia Brendan Murphy
struggling if you're watching you'll see
him visibly struggling not to laugh as
he takes a question from the Australian
media about Donald Trump talking about
hitting the body internally with heat
light and disinfectants during
Thursday's White House coronavirus press
briefing last week professor today at a
briefing Donald Trump said that quote a
tremendous hit unquote of ultraviolet
light could see off the virus he also
referenced the effectiveness of
disinfectant and wondered whether
injections of disinfectant might also be
effective given that this is coming from
the president the United States an
influential person is there any
scientific basis to either of these
propositions I would not I would caution
against the injection of disinfection
there is they could be quite toxic to
people I'm not I wasn't privy to his
comments so I won't be very careful
about commenting on something that I
didn't hear myself certainly and
ultraviolet light I don't know the
context in which he said it so I really
would need to study it and to before I
could comment thank you if you watched
the clip you see the Australian chief
medical officer having difficulty to
avoid bursting out laughing because
that's what the world is currently doing
they're laughing at us and some also
just feel really bad for us I got a
number of nice messages over the weekend
including from friends of mine in other
countries Netherlands Italy other spots
from
Emily in Argentina from viewers in
Canada all who are essentially saying
we're really sorry for what you're
dealing with we're all dealing with the
virus but you were in addition to that
are dealing with Donald Trump here's the
the UK deputy chief medical officer also
ever asked about disinfectant injections
now Donald Trump being treated globally
as a vector of disinformation that must
be debunked time and again let's come
back one more thing many people in the
UK will have seen the clip overnight of
the President of the United States
suggesting coronavirus might be treated
by injecting disinfectant into the body
do you have a message to Donald Trump
about the dangers of spreading dangerous
disinformation when governments around
the world are trying to combat its
spread from other sources here I'll
defer to medical expertise generally and
so I wouldn't have a specific message to
Donald Trump I'd have a specific message
to anybody who suggested they should be
injecting anything into their bodies I
mean clearly we would not support from a
medical professional perspective it is
really important that people use
appropriate treatments that are
evidence-based and tested we have very
good programs that have been taken up
very rapidly coordinated in this country
testing various different alternative
treatments those trials will report
reasonably early but certainly nobody
should be injecting anything and we
should be using evidence-based and
properly trialed treatments that we know
will be safe world disclaimers and
corporations like the makers of Lysol
having to clarify no don't even think
about doing this here's Nicola Sturgeon
the First Minister of Scotland also
having to answer a similar question
actually saying what Trump said could be
dangerous Oh leaders right now there's
always a responsibility on leaders but
it's greater than ever during a crisis
like this and I have said it today I
said it yesterday I'm really keen that
we have an open discussion with the
public and the politicians unusually
perhaps are prepared to admit things
they don't know as well as share the
thinking on the
that we do know we're not trying to work
through but the responsibilities and
leaders is not to stand up in a public
platform and repeat things that you have
perhaps half haired and perhaps
completely misunderstood and present
that to the public in a way that the
public may act on and that could be
dangerous and none of us are perfect we
will all make mistakes in this but I
think we all have to remember that very
serious responsibility when we're giving
advice to the public it must be good
advice informed by it by the best
science and as jason has just said is
clearly not the case that ingesting
disinfectant in any way shape or form is
a good idea there's a very very bad idea
and extremely dangerous and there are
more from all around the world I won't
play them all for you today but this is
now what the world is dealing with we're
all dealing with the virus and the world
is having to come together corporate
America and foreign leaders all having
to come together to say when Trump
wondered aloud about injecting
disinfectants that was a bad idea don't
do it some of them are having trouble
not laughing when they're asked about it
you also by the way have poison control
centers receiving phone calls one
example is from Maryland the governor
Larry Hogan in Maryland is a Republican
he's no left-wing bomb thrower not a
Democrat said Trump was sending the
wrong message with the bleach fiasco and
that his state over the weekend received
hundreds of calls wondering if it is
safe to ingest cleaning products as a
result of Donald Trump's statement
check out the Republican governor here
explaining it many of your citizens
didn't see it as sarcasm is that how you
took it well look I think it's really
important this has been important to me
from day one about communicating very
clearly on the facts because people
listen to these press conferences they
listen when the governor holds a press
conference and they certainly pay
attention when the president of the
United States is standing there giving a
press conference about something as
serious as this worldwide pandemic and
that I I think when misinformation comes
out or you just say something that pops
in your head it does send a wrong
message and we had hundreds of
come into our emergency hotline and our
health department asking if it was if it
was right to ingest Clorox or you know
alcohol cleaning products whether that
was going to help them fight the virus
so we had to put out that warning to
make sure that people were not doing
something like that which would kill
people actually to do it so that's what
happens when the guy who thinks the
Nobel Prize is the Nobel Prize a Toby
Ellie it gets really bad and it's gotten
very very bad and again an unforced
error and we will see what today's press
briefing looks like after all of this
Donald Trump's former White House
communications director Anthony
scaramouche E has again admitted
something which I've been covering for
years at this point which is that Donald
Trump has difficulty reading he really
doesn't read and he struggles to read
Anthony scaramouche E has been doing
interviews recently he's been more
honest than maybe we are used to hearing
from people who worked for Trump or who
worked for Trump and he's admitted to a
number of things including that Donald
Trump can't read very well check out
this clip from an interview with Anand
Giridhar das who's been a previous guest
on the David Pakman show as well I'm not
I'm not I'm not a diagnostician but my
guess is that he probably had an
undiagnosed learning disability as a kid
maybe it's a form of dyslexia or
something like that and so his reading
comprehension levels are not where his
IQ possibly is okay now he's in decline
right now but you'd have to stipulate
that he's a reasonably smart guy I mean
he built a business he built a you know
television show he made a name for
himself and in 17 short months he went
from being a reality television star to
the presidency of the United States so
we have to stipulate that there's
intelligence in there but it's what kind
of intelligence so scaramouche he is
obviously not saying it in as definitive
or aggressive terms as we have suggested
before but scaramouche he also knows
that Trump struggles to read and he
makes it clear there this is not making
fun of people this is not making fun of
learning
abilities this is simply pointing out
don't we need a president who can read
well and regularly reads we suspect
Trump hasn't read a book in his adult
life there's no evidence that Trump has
read a book in his adult life he's never
mentioned reading anything other than
his own book art of the deal which he
didn't write Tony Schwartz wrote it and
the Bible which you know if you believe
Trump reads the Bible okay I may have a
bridge to sell you
but remember that I've been covering
this for years and there's interest in
it and a lot of agreement back in
February of 2017 we did a story called
Trump fails basic literacy test it got
nearly 3.4 million views on YouTube
another 7 million on Facebook this was
subsequently picked up around the world
including in France in other countries
and it explains a lot now not being able
to read well doesn't mean Trump's a bad
person not being able to read well
doesn't mean Trump is wrong on policy he
is usually wrong on policy but for other
reasons but it explains a lot to quote
Donald Trump including things like this
from earlier this week Dickinson
kolodziejczak and Cephei sefa hide this
reading deficit has been widely
corroborated Saturday Night Live's Pete
Davidson said when Trump was hosting SNL
Trump couldn't seem to read the scripts
I've played this clip for you before
what happened with the Trump star guy so
he's like he doesn't really know how to
read for real yeah and he loves to
improv yes so during like the table read
he liked before like we were gonna read
eat before he had to read each line and
he's the host so he's at everything yeah
he would go uh I'm not gonna say this so
they're gonna say it the way I want to
say is it okay do you say is it okay
Lauren is everything that everybody's
like what and then this is my favorite
part is there was a sketch that we wrote
where he's at Disneyland with his
daughter and the line is uh alright
let's get out of here turkey legs like
let's like go get your legs and he he
doesn't know how to read so he went all
right let's get out of here turkey legs
he called his daughter takes this improv
oh no and then he looked at like he
doesn't get it like he thinks if
everybody's laughing with him but we're
all laugh I got it
so that's not new we've covered that
previously no casler worked with Trump
on the apprentice and says Trump
couldn't read although with no casler it
seemed maybe it was more about Trump's
inability to sit still rather than
simply not being able to read no casler
you know we've heard about the possible
uppers stuff with The Apprentice so the
point is we know from sources inside the
White House Trump's presidential daily
briefings have been reduced from what's
normally many pages of text to just a
couple of pages to just one page to just
one page that is half charts and graphs
and even that Trump is accepting with
low frequency so this is not good and
the reason it's not good is because it's
tough to be informed if you're not
reading a lot as president that's how
Barack Obama was informed that's how
George George W Bush read a lot he read
a you know political material he also
just read books we know that doesn't
mean Bush is a great guy doesn't mean he
was a great president but he was reading
at least he came to many wrong decisions
but he was reading Bill Clinton spent a
ton of time reading intelligence
reporting books etc Trump simply doesn't
do it and all politics aside that's a
fundamental liability when you're
President of the United States
it's sad more than anything but it has a
real effect on Trump's ability to be a
leader and it's not a good effect I'll
tell you that right now
it uh it sort of pains me to say this
because we've been saying for months we
need to be primarily led by doctors
about the virus not by politicians but
dr. deborah birx
has become a primary disseminator of
laughable trumpian propaganda and dr.
Burks is no longer a trustworthy source
of information in this entire thing it
doesn't mean everything she says is
wrong but she is no longer a trustworthy
source overall dr. deborah birx actually
defended Donald Trump's outrageous
comment
about bleach injections as Trump talking
out loud and having dialogue in real
time as he synthesizes and assimilates
data that he has been presented now
there is a really important tell here in
the video I'm about to play for you that
what dr. Burks is saying is BS let's
look at the videos very short 25 seconds
see if you can pick out the tell that
dr. Burks is being dishonest no when he
gets new information he likes to talk
that through out loud and really have
that dialogue and so that's what
dialogue he was happening at having I
think he just saw the information at the
time immediately before the press
conference and he was still digesting
that information so the tell there that
shows us that dr. Burks is being
dishonest is that she had the idea to
say Oh Trump had just seen this
information for the first time meaning a
minute before he made this crazy bleach
comment but the problem is that Donald
Trump said during the meeting during the
briefing he had already received this
briefing about disinfectants earlier in
the day and as dr. Burks is saying or
about to say Trump was reacting in
real-time as he learned about this she
realizes wait a second I can't say that
because that would contradict Trump
Trump already said during the briefing I
got this briefing earlier and I thought
it was so interesting I wanted it
presented here so in real time dr. Burks
extends her sentence and says I think he
just saw the information at the time
pause immediately before the press
conference
check out that pause as dr. Burks
realized as oh wait a second I need to
say more or this is going to be
obviously a lie and so that's what
dialogue he was happening at having I
think he just saw the information at the
time immediately before the press
conference and he was still digesting
that information so she is now a trump
brown-noser she's refusing to tell it
like it is on prematurely openings she
resisted saying that it was a concerning
decision that Florida made ten days ago
to reopen beaches or whenever it was and
remember that she also made this
absolutely insane claim a few weeks ago
about how Donald Trump just uses data to
make decisions and all of the stuff that
we simply
is not true and Trump has no attention
span for how would you describe the job
president Trump is doing behind the
scenes and in front of the cameras
during these daily briefings that we're
seeing what's been your perspective dr.
Burks he's been so attentive to the
scientific literature and the details
and the data and I think his his ability
to analyze it integrate data that comes
out of his long history in business has
really been a real benefit during these
discussions about medical issues because
in the end data is data and he
understands the importance of the
granularity and I think he's been really
excited about finding the level of
detail that we've been able to now bring
over the last few weeks to really
understand who's at the greatest risk
for severe illness what Trump is
analyzing data at a granular level to
understand the details of this pandemic
that interview was back when Trump had
more recently said we have 15 cases and
we will soon have zero this is the Trump
that last week wondered aloud about
injecting bleach and isopropyl alcohol
to treat coronavirus obviously it's a
lie Trump has been the opposite of what
dr. deborah birx claims so we've talked
before about a doctor making this
calculation that if they disagree with
from too much they get fired and if they
get fired they get replaced by some
total trump sycophant and the country is
worth worse off doctor foul he made it
clear he said listen I can't jump in
front of the microphone
every single time Trump says something
and correct him it's just not feasible
but as you've seen doctor foul she has
been sidelined from the press briefings
for a while now dr. Burks has gone fully
into not just I won't contradict Trump
when he lies she's starting to do this
sort of sycophantic stuff that reminds
me of Donald Trump's crazy letter from
his doctor saying Trump would be the
healthiest president ever that's the
type of disinformation that dr. Burks is
now a part of and it's terrible because
we are at a desperate deficit of actual
a trustworthy medical professionals that
our administration adjacent
unfortunately dr. Burks can no longer be
trusted and there are people writing to
me saying you know Burks has Stockholm
Syndrome she's starting to side with her
pack their captor I don't know about
that the only thing that could be said
is dr. Burks believes that she can do
more as a part of the task force than
not out than out of it and she believes
that she has to be saying these things
about Trump as transparently
unbelievable as they are in order to
remain on the task force that's the most
optimistic interpretation of what dr.
Burks has been saying but to go on
Christian Broadcasting and say Trump
synthesizes data in this great way and
other transparently untrue things it
seems like it's overkill let me know
what you believe is going on with dr.
Burks what explains her behavior and
also let me know what you think is going
on with dr. fowey who's been missing
from the press briefings for more than a
week now despite Donald Trump every once
in a while
alluding to or even saying straight-up
oh yeah well you know don't tony was
part of the meeting earlier what do you
make of that I want to hear from you and
we will have continued coverage of this
and other stories from today's program
on the David Pakman show Instagram page
if you are on Instagram you can do much
worse than following at David Pakman
show on Instagram so let's continue to
get caught up about the aftermath of
Donald Trump wondering aloud about
injecting bleach and isopropyl alcohol
as a possible treatment for coronavirus
he said it he floated the idea that it
was sarcasm that failed so Friday he
left the press briefing without taking a
single question we then learned he would
be reducing the brunt number and
duration of press briefings but more
importantly Trump spent the entire
weekend rage tweeting attacks on media
for all of this and that's the move you
you he tried claiming it was sarcasm and
that failed he you know denying that he
ever said it has obviously failed since
we have cameras in 2020 and we can
record things so Trump spent the whole
weekend with dozens of tweets including
some that he is deleted out of shame
attacking the media for all of this once
again another
of Trump's authoritarian totalitarian
tendencies attack the press constantly
for everything while never taking
responsibility so let's take a look at
or through Trump's weekend rage tweeting
starting with lies about virus testing
Trump saying many testing sites are and
have been open and available just past
five million tests far more than any
other country in the world in fact more
than all other major countries combined
don't believe the fake news now that's
just a short statement but it's riddled
with lies first of all what matters is
testing per capita we are forty first
and testing per capita the total number
of tests doesn't matter that much but
also remember that the Trump
administration promised that we would
have done more than twenty million tests
by the end of March it's the end of
April and we've done only five million
but Trump insists it's the media that is
lying to you now he's the one lying to
you then going into Bleach injection
saying quote was just informed that the
fake news from the Thursday White House
press conference had me speaking and
asking questions of dr. Burks wrong I
was speaking to our laboratory expert
not Debora about sunlight etc and the
coronavirus the lamestream media is
corrupt and sick now of course the video
is very cleared from turns to her and
literally says Debora have you heard of
injecting heat and light and she says
well there is this thing called fever so
again it's another lie but a pointless
lie it's neither here nor there in Trump
wondering aloud about bleach and
isopropyl injections then maybe Trump's
ki tweet of the weekend now defending
why he won't be doing press briefings of
course the real reason he's gonna pare
them down is it's become an
embarrassment he says it's because of
the media tweeting quote what is the
purpose of having White House news
conferences when the lamestream media
asks nothing but hostile questions and
then refuses to report the truth or
facts accurately they get record ratings
and the American people get nothing but
fake news not worth the time and effort
he said something that is the source of
international shame for the United
States that's why he's being advised to
pare down the meetings
he attacks the media as the reason and
unfortunately it probably works with
many of his followers another media
attack remember this is the president in
the midst of a pandemic spending his
entire weekend tweeting stuff like this
saying quote I never said the pandemics
was a hoax who would do such a thing
I said that the do-nothing Democrats
together with their mainstream media
partners are the hoax they have been
called out and embarrassed on this even
admitting they were wrong but continue
to spread the lie remember it's Trump
who's been called out and embarrassed
internationally for saying what about
injecting bleach and of course he did
refer to it as a hoax many times then
amid numerous well sourced reports that
Trump has recently been watching five to
seven hours of news every morning before
strolling into work at noon Trump says
quote the people that know me and know
the history of our country say that I am
the hardest-working president in history
I don't know about that but I am a hard
worker and have probably gotten more
done in the first three and a half years
than any president in history the fake
news hates it that one obviously alive
but we don't really need to debunk it
and then this is the cherry on top a
three tweet gong show where he said and
subsequently deleted because of the
embarrassing misspellings when will all
of the reporters who have received Nobel
prizes and I'm saying not Nobel noble
and Oh ble Nobel Prizes for their work
on Russia Russia Russia only two have
been proven totally wrong and in fact it
was the other side who committed the
crimes be turning back their cherished
nobles again an o BL es so that they can
be given to the real reporters and
journalists who got it right I can give
the committee a very comprehensive list
when with will the Nobel Committee
demand the prizes back that this is one
sentence folks especially since they
were gotten under fraud the reporters
and lamestream media knew the truth all
along lawsuits should be brought against
all including the fake news
organizations that's capital F capital
and capital o to rectify this terrible
in
for all of the great lawyers out there
do they have any takers
when will the Nobel Committee act that's
a capital A on Act better be fast those
were deleted I assume because of Nobel
vs Nobel but also maybe because it is
the adjutant some other kind of
medication to be tweeting out not the
President of the United States in the
middle of a Sunday afternoon an entire
weekend after a globally embarrassing
debacle attacking media and press as the
source of his problems this is not a
well man we're gonna do a deep dive
later in the week about how this has
become a sort of last straw for a lot of
people around the world to realize that
this man is fundamentally unwell but
what matters here in the u.s. is whether
our voters realize it people in Germany
realizing Trump is sick doesn't really
help remove them in November if
Americans who don't vote realized frump
is sick it also doesn't help remove him
in November people who are going to vote
or who can be convinced to vote they are
the ones who need to realize it and I
don't know that they are this is kind of
a funny coda to the Trump bleach
injection Fiasco after Trump wondered
aloud about whether disinfectants like
isopropyl alcohol and bleach could be
injected or otherwise introduced into
the body to treat coronavirus a whole
bunch of Trumpets denied that he said it
the next day Trump admitted to saying it
but he claimed it was sarcasm and then
he took no pressed questions at a press
briefing later that day and trumpets are
now dealing with conflicting defenses
what some are saying he never said it
others are saying it was sarcasm and
Trump admitted to saying it and says it
was sarcasm but it doesn't appear Trump
knows what sarcasm is maybe shockingly
longtime Fox News and Fox Business
anchor Neil Cavuto plain and simple just
admitted Trump wasn't joking this wasn't
sarcasm and it's extra funny by the way
to hear Neil Cavuto reading the quote
off of a transcript let's let's indulge
together marks yesterday when he talked
about injecting people with disinfectant
nor were we imagining the
credulous loads he got from his medical
team when he made the suggestion there
was nothing in those comments yesterday
that hinted of the dismissal he was
giving today now he did waive it aside
that that was not what he intended but
that is what he said that injecting
people with disinfectant for coronavirus
showed some great promise he said I
think you've said you're going to test
that too and it sounds interesting he
went on to say then I see that if that
infect disinfectant where it knocks it
out in a minute in one minute is there a
way we can do something like that by
injection inside or almost a cleaning
because you see it gets in the lungs
here he's referring to the corona virus
and it does a tremendous number on the
lungs again referring to the corona
virus he said it would be interesting to
check that so that you're going to have
to use medical doctors with this but it
it sounds interesting to me he is
talking about injecting products like
Lysol into your body to see if that can
combat the disease that is what he said
now he might be dialing that back today
I don't know why he just didn't say look
I screwed up I got it wrong that wasn't
my intention this is an important
medical distinction so much so that the
makers of Lysol came out and said no no
do not inject our product in to your
body notice how Neil Cavuto says Trump
should have just said hey I got it wrong
I was just wrong on this one where is
Neil Cavuto been for the last twenty
years and especially the last three and
a half with Donald Trump as president
has Trump ever just showed up and said I
I misspoke I was wrong about x y&z no he
took a sharpie and modified a weather
map when saying I was just wrong would
have been the right thing to do now one
other thing about Kabuto Kabuto actually
goes on to debunk Trump's claim that
only Chinese studies are saying
hydroxychloroquine might be bad for
people taking coronavirus here's Kabuto
saying this is data from our own FDA
that says it might be time to cut it
with the hydroxi secondly he goes on to
say on these findings they're still
unresolved on
to chloroquine and chloroquine it was
the fda not a study in china that that
said that kovat 19 outside of hospital
settings or clinical trials is is not to
be combined with any treatments of
hydroxychloroquine or chloroquine that
that having an outside of these venues
there is a high risk of heart rhythm
problems I just want a very clarify that
these were not some outside entities
this was the FDA saying whoa whoa
outside of these settings there are risk
so this other study that that it's got
some worried that maybe that the
president was trying to dismiss that has
to do with the use of this to treat to
treat those with this condition now the
president has often said that which
drops of chloro getting these others
what have you got to lose well in a VA
study of a few hundred of our veterans
the risk is they have to lose their
lives Neil Cavuto has of course since
been fired by Fox News I'm kidding
but I do want to be careful here because
Cavuto has been a vector of
disinformation for decades on Fox News
he's been on Fox News for 23 20 I think
since day one since 1996 so we don't
need to go out of our way to praise him
big picture the same way that just
because Trump is wildly more
cartoonishly sick than Bush was we don't
need to go out of our way to praise
george w bush but Cavuto spent a bunch
of Friday's show debunking Trump's lies
which is good because that's the
audience that needs to hear it most most
acutely the other angle is that we're
increasingly seeing Fox concern just
about the legal repercussions of how
they've portrayed coronavirus from day
one there's a study released last week
that suggests if you watch Sean Hannity
more than Tucker you were more likely to
get the virus which sort of tracks with
Hannity being much more flippant and
minimizing of the risk from coronavirus
so the stuff has a real impact if Neil
Cavuto really wanted to do the full
story
it would include mentioning that if
Trump was joking
when he said inject bleach that's one
question
but if he was joking what is the joke
like what's the punchline they're
watching this is a very weird experience
because the tone of Neil Cavuto voice is
almost like he's surprised that Trump
lied multiple times during the press
briefing Trump's been lying during every
single one of these press briefings
since day one good for Neil Cavuto for
calling out to lies that it was
sarcastic and that hydroxi is working
but still big picture Neil Cavuto seems
surprised that these press briefings are
nothing but opportunities to disseminate
lies and disinformation we're going to
have clips from all of this
on our Instagram page so make sure
you're following us on instagram at
david pakman show I also on my personal
Instagram will be posting a time-lapse
of my tomato plants rising like the
Phoenix to like about an inch sprout
anyway that's on my Instagram at David
Pakman so of course we have to talk
about the Donald Trump bleach injection
Fiasco that over the weekend has turned
from an offhanded dumb comment into
really a catalyst of absolute
international shame which has pushed
Donald Trump into hiding over the
weekend in the midst of a global
pandemic which he had mismanaged from
the get-go and is now set to surpass
this week
the total number of deaths that Donald
Trump has been predicting Donald Trump
of course talking about 60,000
coronavirus deaths the United States
already as of right now at almost 56,000
and every indication that we will
surpass that number this week and we
have now this unforced error once again
of bleach injections so please allow me
some time in today's show to really go
through some of the different elements
of this and to catch you up if you
checked out of the news altogether for
the last 72 hours you may not have heard
of this but otherwise you probably know
that Donald Trump wondered aloud in this
tone which he has perfected which is a
tone that implies his ideas are absolute
genius and how has not how has nobody
else thought of this stuff
Trump wondered allow
what if we injected disinfect infect ins
like bleach and isopropyl alcohol which
were the ones just previously in the
press briefing mentioned and put up on
screen what if we introduced those into
the body through injection or some other
means to treat coronavirus now of course
these are toxic chemicals they have
large warning labels on them saying this
this can kill you don't drink this don't
ingest this in any way here's the source
of the insanity that kicked off the last
three or four days of madness we hit the
body with a tremendous whether it's
ultraviolet or just very powerful light
and I think you said that hasn't been
checked but you're going to test it and
then I said supposing you brought the
light inside the body you can which you
can do either through the skin or in
some other way and I think you said
you're gonna test that too sounds
interesting
right and then I see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute one
minute and is there way we can do
something like that by injection inside
or almost of cleaning because you see it
gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number of along so it'd be
interesting to check that so that you're
gonna have to use medical doctors with
but it sounds it sounds interesting to
me so we'll see but the whole concept of
the light the way it kills it in one
minute that's that's pretty powerful
absolute international embarrassment
will discuss that international global
shame momentarily shockingly or maybe
not from fists immediately started
falling over themselves to defend Donald
Trump some started saying he never said
it he simply never said it others
suggesting well it was a joke others
saying it was taken completely out of
context and unfortunately this is one of
those cases where the more context you
get the more clear it is that it was
accurately reported now there are people
saying that Trump could have simply met
different disinfectants like for example
he could have met medical grade
antivirals which disinfect the body or
whatever no here's a picture that was on
the screen moments before Trump used the
word it clearly says commonly available
disinfect
bleach and isopropyl alcohol Trump turns
around and talks about the disinfectants
you're talking about putting them in the
body instead of using them to disinfect
a desk for example that's what he meant
so of course he said it now at one crazy
moment Donald Trump turns to dr. deborah
birx and asks her what about applying
heat and light to treat this dr. Burks
in the way only she can as an
unfortunately growing vector of
disinformation for Donald Trump
she bails Trump out by saying well there
is this thing called fever that's sort
of like heat in the body right check it
out I have to say covers a lot more
territory than just this this is this is
probably an easy thing relatively
speaking for you I would like you to
speak to the medical doctors to see if
there's any way that you can apply light
and heat to cure you know if you could
and maybe you can maybe you can't again
I say maybe you can maybe I can't I'm
not a doctor but I'm like a person that
has a good you know what the heat and
the light relative to certain viruses
yes but relative to this virus that is a
treatment any certainly fever is a good
thing when you have a fever it helps
your body responds but not as I've not
seen okay and then here is dr. Steven
Hahn the FDA Commissioner having to
answer questions during an interview
with CNN's Anderson Cooper and dr.
Sanjay Gupta about this if you are
watching pay particularly close
attention to the expression the look on
dr. Sanjay Gupta's face as this insanity
is going on I will remind you this is
not a simulation this is not a drill
this is real life there is there any
evidence about taking a disinfectant
that's used you know on the table where
I'm sitting and using it internally that
doesn't seem like a good idea from my I
mean am I wrong yes I think it's an
excellent point you're making you you we
serve
we wouldn't want as a physician someone
to take matters in their own hands I
think this is a something that a patient
would want to talk to their physician
about and and no I certainly wouldn't
recommend the internal ingestion of a
disinfectant again this is a
conversation that occurs every day in
America between a patient and dr. Ivan
in that position I'm sure dr. Gupta has
as well and it's really important that
we address them because people will ask
those questions of us well doctor and I
just just I think we should be clear
though that the idea of doing some kind
of UV light therapy which is sometimes
used for local issues in the body but
not for a widespread viral infection and
the idea of injecting disinfectant I
mean there's no those questions may be
getting asked but there's absolutely no
merit to that that doesn't need to be
studied you can already say that that
doesn't work right and I and I think
such a that that that is exactly what a
patient would say to a doctor and that
would be the answer of the medical
experts to anybody who answered that
question right questions like should I
inject bleach our questions really meant
for doctor and patient that's where
those a thank you dr. Han for clearing
that up
absolutely shocking so the end result is
that Donald Trump during Friday's press
briefing the day after this took place
abruptly ended it and walked out without
answering a single question we learned
that right before the briefing Trump
staffers came out and they tried to
reposition CNN reporter Caitlin Collins
to the back of the room normally she
sits near the front clearly they were
expecting her to ask about this as she
should and the reporters agreed we
decide where we sit you don't decide
where it is that we sit and after they
refused to switch places after CNN
reporter Caitlin Collins refused to be
pushed to the back of the room
Donald Trump simply left without taking
a single question something he's not
done since the start of the press
briefings take a look I truly do believe
the day will soon come when we will heal
our land and we'll be able to reopen
America and put this great nation back
to work
[Music]
so typically when Trump raps you get 30
minutes 60 minutes sometimes even more
of Trump answering questions
Trump instead just leaving now a couple
of other things we'll talk more about
Trump being and hiding momentarily but
Donald Trump has been hugely triggered
by all of this and we don't know what
the form or frequency of future
briefings will be one was scheduled for
today we don't know whether questions
will be taken we know that people around
Trump are telling him you're doing
yourself more harm than good with these
this is not good but in the meantime
notice the degree to which simply
quoting Trump verbatim triggers his
supporters over the weekend I got into a
crazy back-and-forth on Twitter with
Dilbert cartoonist Scott Adams who has
become a big vector of disinformation
and defensive Trump and he ended up
angrily blocking me you can look at look
at the Twitter history of it if it's
interesting to you but he was
increasingly triggered merely by people
telling him you're just denying what
Trump said here's the quote oh it's
missing context here's more context and
it is exactly as reported Trump
wondering aloud what if we take the
disinfectants you're talking about and
put them into the body let's next
discuss Donald Trump in hiding at some
point tomorrow I might devote some time
to talking about how dr. deborah birx
has really become a vector of donald
trump disinformation covering up his
incompetence and suggesting he has a
clue but for today I want to talk more
generally about the fact that doctors
are being pushed out of the picture when
it comes to Trump's White House
coronavirus task force and that dr.
Anthony foul she has essentially been
disappeared by Donald Trump from the
press briefings over time pouchy has had
a smaller and smaller role he used to
stand on the stage in view of the
cameras then he was on the stage out of
view of the cameras but he would come up
if asked a question then he would sit on
the side and come up if someone had a
question lately
he's just not been at the briefings at
all now in conjunction with this we have
a new report that this is part of a
calculated trend where Donald Trump is
going to be pushing doctors away from
the briefings and instead the briefings
as we know we don't know whether
questions will or won't even be allowed
after Thursday's Fiasco but it is going
to be an economically based briefing and
I'm guessing part of that is if you only
talk about economics you reduce the
chances of wondering aloud about
injecting bleach if there's one person
who should be at every briefing it's dr.
Anthony foutch II he's been running
infectious disease for the US for 35
years he's actually an expert on global
pandemic he's actually a medical doctor
he had been at almost every one of the
first 45 or so briefings and then
suddenly he's gone we know why it's
happening the more of a fool that Trump
makes out of himself the more Anthony
foul G is asked to contradict Donald
Trump and foul she's been careful we've
talked about this before foul she has
said you know I can't jump up every time
Trump says something wrong and interrupt
the president and correct him he would
be fired if he did that and foul she my
guesses has calculated his presence and
his role being maintained in any form is
better than being fired and being
replaced with some kind of total trump
sycophant who may not even really know
anything about infectious disease so
more and more now pouchy questions are
being asked to Trump you said X and
doctor foul she said why can you explain
that are you not on the same page and
Trump tends to say I didn't see it you
know I don't know what Anthony said they
are now pulling foul Qi further away and
the defense from the White House is foul
she does lots of other things other than
just go to the briefings he has many
other responsibilities well okay but
didn't he have those responsibilities
during the 45 meetings he did attend for
more than a month until he was just
disappeared and we know why it's being
done now she continues to say we need to
ramp up testing dramatically Trump says
testing is fine and we have the most in
the world
of course we're 42nd in testing per
capita Trump said in a recent briefing
the virus may not
back in the fall doctor foul Qi said in
that same briefing we will have
coronavirus with us in the fall and then
in the midst of all this about foul Qi
we learn that the White House wants to
just get away from doctors altogether at
the briefing and talk about economics
instead White House official telling
Axios that the press briefings will
continue but that the virus stuff will
take a backseat if you can imagine while
economic stuff and a more
forward-looking message talking about
opening her up and stuff like that is
what we are going to hear so that's code
for stocks and reopening and v-shaped
recovery discussions rather than death
toll vaccinations therapeutics and it's
an election focused strategy Axios
reports that there are officials who
have told Trump this is hurting you the
press briefings are hurting you and your
polling against Biden in particular
among older Americans is imploding so
the bottom line of the strategy is the
longer this goes on into worse for Trump
that's clear if the press briefings
become a daily reminder that Trump just
keeps bragging about the same things
every day
the death toll stays high and continues
climbing that's bad for Trump in
November the November election will be a
trump referendum but it's going to be
more a referendum on the economy than on
the virus and what I mean by that is
Trump has obviously bungled the virus
response but changing your vote based on
the virus response does not seem hugely
likely for reasons we discussed last
week with Rachel bitter coffer on the
other hand we know one of the main
things that determines does an incumbent
president get reelected or removed is
the perception of the state of the
economy around the time of the election
this would explain why Trump would move
to an economic message while doctors
continue to be pushed into the
background tomorrow we'll have an
updated report on testing and in the
meantime I would love for dr. fowey to
start doing his own daily updates on
YouTube my guess is he would be fired
for that so what we have is a global
hundred year pandemic the United States
is choosing to sideline the medical
professionals
to talk about stocks and reopening
barbershops that's where we are right
now and it's embarrassing